there are going to be some big changes
of Paramount some big changes for Star
Trek potentially welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV a movie channel
[Music]
so in the last couple of days Paramount
has released its quarterly results and
the um CEO um Bob backish and CFO Naveen
Chopra have been talking about those
results and their plans moving forward
to pound that plus they've been talking
about how they've been building data
over the last couple of years during
Paramount Plus's existence and that
they're now ready to start making some
big sweeping changes across the platform
they have figured out that they can
focus their television and movie plans
to certain key audiences they keep
calling it super serving and that they
now have a lot of data to support their
decisions now I have a couple of
contacts that work in and around certain
aspects of this field one contact in
particular who used to work at MGM and
now works at quite a large marketing
firm has reported to me that they've
been doing a lot of work for Paramount
I've actually spoken to them before and
and videos about Star Trek thanks to
this source so when all this got
released yesterday I gave the source a
phone call and asked them basically to
explain it to me and he's actually been
able to tell me that they have advised
Paramount regarding Star Trek and other
projects and actually some of the advice
will make certain aspects of the Trekker
family very very happy so first of all
what is this super serve
well parent has been building
um demographic data for quite some time
they've been basically looking at who
watches Paramount plus what sort of
person actually then keeps the
subscription so if they watch so many
hours a week watch this type of show
watch this type of show are they more
likely or less likely to then keep the
subscription long term those are the
people they mean by targeted audiences
these are the people they want to
actually tailor the television moving
forwards for now my source has been able
to tell me that the sort of things that
Paramount will be focusing far more on
are things like lionesses the more
recent sort of military style mystery
sort of show
um High Thriller high intensity High
action
they will also be though keeping Star
Trek as the Jewel of the crown 4
Paramount plus but
it will be a little bit different my
source me now to tell me that actually
his company working in conjunction with
another company has actually recommended
the a list of basically a franchises
that they suggest Parliament should
focus on Star Trek was on that list but
apparently they also recommended that
there has been too much Star Trek on
Paramount plus and that they're in
danger of saturating the market now
paramounts plus plan with Star Trek was
to basically have several different
shows within the franchise that targeted
different demographics so we had
discovery that actually has quite a
young demographic a younger audience we
have things like Picard That was
supposed to satisfy trekkies like myself
in that 35 to 45 sort of demographic
bracket we had lower decks which is
again more aimed at me and we had
um Prodigy which is supposed to again be
aimed at a younger audience or really a
kids audience following the
recommendations France certain companies
like the one my source works for
that has led to Prodigy being actually
farmed off to a third party the thinking
was twofold one apparently that just
Prodigy wasn't getting a big enough
audience not enough people were watching
it but also not enough people were
clicking and talking about it online so
they said basically the route to grow
the show just wasn't there So the plan
was to remove it from Paramount it was a
very conscious decision to do it very
suddenly it was supposed to shock and
surprise us and then move it to a third
party I'm hearing The Prodigy will
actually be moving to Amazon but
apparently that's not been finalized
just yet so the idea being was to shock
the fans and get them online that worked
beautifully the online petition has well
gone beyond anything that the fans did
for strange new worlds when they were
desperate for that show
there's been a lot more interest in
Prodigy there's been a lot more
attention I mean just look at Star Trek
Live Las Vegas they had a big
announcement that a clip from series two
of Prodigy had been released and put out
there it did cause a lot of excitement I
have never really noticed a lot of
traffic regarding Prodigy before this
announcement and now my Twitter feed or
whatever it's called there is full of
Star Trek Prodigy stuff so that strategy
worked very effectively now people are
talking about Prodigy and will follow it
to whatever third party it ends up on I
asked my source is there a chance for a
season three of Prodigy and he said that
is another reason why they farmed it off
because they didn't really want to go
through the third season but this way
it's not up to them anymore
whoever they end up selling it to if it
is Amazon Prime it will be up to them
whether they commission a third season
or not so there's a little bit of good
news there a third season of Prodigy is
actually possible
but what else has been recommended well
the big recommendation apparently was
that they should drop
Star Trek Academy or at very least turn
it into a one-off miniseries rather than
a full-on series to replace discovery
they have also recommended that they
should only be running three Star Trek
series at a time and we should probably
only see two of those per year so the
calendar will be stretched out now I
think we've already seen that a little
bit we've seen that plan sort of being
actioned a little bit but we will only
see two series per annual calendar year
of Star Trek
so we can look at maybe it being like 13
14 15 months between each season of
strange new worlds lower decks Etc as I
said it was recommended that they
changed the plan for Star Trek Academy
and that they push forward plans for
Star Trek Legacy now I was told a little
while ago that there was one plan to
actually end strange new Worlds at
season three and then replace that with
Star Trek Legacy now I've heard that
rumor a few times but it's very much in
the room a category so I'm not going to
put any weight behind it I don't know
for certain if that's true or not but my
source did suggest that actually that
could be true that Strange New World's
numbers have been variable at best and
actually three seasons was kind of
always the initial plan that they never
actually thought to go beyond that very
similar to what they did with Stark
Picard that three seasons is always the
plan to begin with and that we'll be
getting a big third season following
what we're going at the moment and that
actually then strange new worlds will be
ending we will see if that happens
because I think it very much depends on
the popularity strange new world has got
into the top 10 Nielsen chart the chart
that basically looks at the top 10
streaming shows across all of the
platforms Star Trek Picard also did but
Discovery Etc never have
but I would argue actually that this
season this strange new world has been a
little bit variable with its numbers
some of them have not been great so that
is what the marketing people the
companies the parliament are going to to
actually look at all the numbers they've
been building and to do basically little
projects to give them recommendations a
saying drop Star Trek Academy and push
forward plans for Star Trek Legacy only
have maximum of three seasons running at
any one time stretch the calendar out so
we only actually get two things a year
and it will then be plus the TV movie
every other year this way making sure
that you've got enough of the Star Trek
that people really love but not too much
and that really is a key point that the
marketing people are saying you can
saturate the market you can get fatigue
of Star Trek and that will end up
killing the franchise like it did
following Star Trek Enterprise if
they're not careful the marketing people
are basically saying you need to build
up a little bit of excitement you need
to have people waiting for these series
you need to actually then drop them
weekly not all together
like pan I've been doing for quite some
time and that needs to be the focus
moving forward and I'd love to know what
you guys think about that is that a good
idea or does it basically mean we're
going to be stifling a bit of creativity
what do you think about this Star Trek
plan if that's what Paramount decided to
do does that make sense to you or do you
think no I want more damn it get to the
comments and tell me exactly what you
think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small
contribution each month the really
Sports channel you get to see them
without the adverts as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]